It's Friday and that means it's
time for Friday follies Yes
toxic masculinity and art
what to avoid on Black Friday
it's almost over and Jon Voight
helps Raymond's couture joining
us with all the very important
details is Raymond Arroyo Fox
News contributor Raymond I
thought we were done with this
whole toxic masculinity issue
but now apparently it's making
its debut at a museum.
What's happening the Baltimore
Museum of Art has announced
that next year it will only be
purchasing art created by women
forget Roe Dan singer
Sargent Michelangelo
Renoir out with them.
Here's how the museum director
Christopher Bedford explains
the decision he writes I would
say the 2020 vision is just
an extension of the code of
ethics that had been deeply
embedded within
the museum building
a permanent
collection is building
a story for all time a story.
Apparently Laura without men I
mean well how do you help women
by exempting men from the museum
this is crazy maybe I should
just do an entire show with just
women right to see just imagine
if I just announced that well
I mean really what do you mean
there's both everyone's supposed
to be just judged on their own
merits your own value they
make their own choices and now
you're you are actually
having your worth
determined by the sex
that you were born with.
And how does that make any sense
one of the artists Laura Lisa
bailout Morehead who will
be featured in the Baltimore
Museum of Art she has great
hopes for this gender exclusive
approach she says I'm hoping
that all of us can start
to think about how patriarchy
and hierarchy has really
diminished people's interests
in museums and cultural centers
this will live in the audience
it's just the right thing to do
well this is the wrong thing
to do the right thing to do is
to let art stand on its own and
let people judge what is worthy
or not worthy for inclusion
based on how it looks and what
audience it can draw not by
who painted the Raymond and what
plumbing they have Raymond back
in college and my college
newspaper we would rip
the whole idea of studies like a
women in history and literature
and African-Americans in
history and literature but now
everything is studies and
every group has a studies well
and women's studies, et cetera.
And I just take it balkanized as
people as aggregate some black
and white and and it segregates
thought which is crazy I will
say that Raymond has a tendency
of doing that he's usually
sitting right here next to
me when he's doing a segment
but he has been known to take
his iPhone out and adjust his
tie I do and also do the check
the lights for various parts
of his head that might be shiny
so I was told by the producers
that when you sat down with
Voight the other day Jon Voight
there was a moment
let's watch can I stand
or no you see I don't know.
I was driven I was going to fix
his tie it was your damn thing
over with you which way that's
it they push it all the way
over there you've got to you've
gotta do it yourself way over
to the left way
over to the left,
you'd never go to the left John
why are you making me is this
what I came to see her guide
enter push it that I know I
know while trying
I'm trying look
I'm using you Yes No you're not
doing it now now pull it tight.
I'll pull it OK now
you're really tight.
You got it that's it OK he fixed
it but I do onion powder now
I'm sledding a lot oh you are
so fucked Billy really got you
this went on for five minutes
with silk ties they move on you
if you don't like guns or not
they move you have to adjust
and John got a little frustrated
and he's a great pal so he
really meant to help me I have a
question is this the first time
you've attempted to not the
Cravath OK oh what what's that
you don't know how to not your
own time like I'm dealing with
Dimitri or Niko myself this
was the first time I've had
an Academy Award winner
helped me adjust the tie so your
plan that I didn't land that I
didn't party was this is a
great Christmas chip for you you
could get me clip on ties that
don't move this is I have those
my sons have that for their
schoolbooks they have to wear
a jacket Yeah they have that tie
with a little expand the band
behind so you just throw you
they just have it hanging over
their necks and then they go in
over a zip feature its own food
get me a clip on tie I'm going
to get you some earrings that
go over the ears as I'm
going to tell the story
about the earrings at some
point but this is the longest
tease ever of why the earrings
always fall out but we have
we have too much shopping
anticipation building up in this
show tonight so I don't think
we can do we can't we can't
discuss them that's just too
much excitement in
one show can't do
it all all right all
right have a good
weekend great to see you.